The Joe Rogan Experience but the
question is like why would we assume
that it's a biological entity it doesn't
have any windows it's this round thing
that looks like a Tic Tac if there is
some sort of advanced propulsion system
some some revolutionary way of moving
through space and time that the US
government has developed you know in
some Black Ops program that seems very
likely impossible that seems more likely
than aliens visiting us but there's more
than one incident and there's a lot of
these things and the possibility of
alien life in the universe although
we've never experienced it seems
rational it seems very rational and if
you were going to study an emerging
civilization that is both primitive and
warlike and yet insanely technologically
advanced to the point where they have
nuclear weapons they could transmit
video through the sky they have
propaganda they have tracking of their
citizens like that's us that's us right
now and while we are these territorial
Primal beings with [__] nuclear
weapons this would be a good time yeah
to start exposing yourself yes and to
stop this nonsense yeah and look
the reason why we named uh the rooms in
our club fat man and little boy is
because in UFO lore that's when they
started showing up after the detonation
the atomic bombs in Japan that's when
the UFO sightings ramped up and they ran
mostly in the U.S right yes so that's
interesting because the US was the one
that was the nuclear power so and we
were the one who was doing a lot of
[__] testing yeah you know and also
we have all these military bases who the
[__] has more military bases than us who
has more nuclear weapons pointed at
other people than us we're we have them
all over the place and there's all these
multiple sightings and eyewitness
accounts of like very credible people
who say these things have hovered over
military bases it'd be pretty cool if uh
these aliens were benevolent overlords
and they were like hey my children yeah
or maybe even so Advanced intellectually
that the concept of an Overlord is
preposterous and they're just biological
management they're just there's just the
gardeners tending to make sure the weeds
don't get out of hand and just like let
this process continue to play itself out
because this process of technological
innovation is
the everything that humans do yeah it's
what we do at the Pinnacle of our
creation is we make better technology
well I always wonder about fractals and
whether or not like this idea of this
being a simulation this being you know
uh like we are we are kind of
replicating we are creating machines and
doing our best to create them in our own
image right yes and that's interesting
you know that's because our the the
mythologies that we subscribe to are the
idea that this God that we pray to made
us in His image and we're doing the same
thing now with robots and and computers
and that's an interesting thing that we
see to seem to have this sort of um
Paradigm this this this idea that that
um that's the scaffolding for the way we
think right and to what end and and why
are we doing that maybe it's an address
it already happened but has it already
happened are we are we the result of
that that
um impulse
that happened way longer a long time ago
I think we are the [__] throwing chimps
that are going to become the nuclear
physicist that's what we are the [__]
throwing chimps from 2001 to become
Oppenheimer yeah yeah and then I think
this thing that we become is integrated
with technology it's probably some sort
of a hybrid it's some sort of a cyborg
that's wild because I think we're
already like on the verge of merging you
know all this talk of like neuralink and
all these various things we watched this
video the other day of this guy who is
uh Googling questions and getting
answers in his head with his headpiece
on it seen that thing yeah yeah that's
so crazy incredible right so how long
before that is like that's pong I don't
know and then you have the unreal four
engine in 2023 that looks like a movie
no like how long before that technology
gets to the point where it's just
supremely Advanced and we we literally
are like God but my question really is
also the idea that that's engineering
right that's a tool it's Innovation it
but but there's there's and engineering
so there are two aspects to it one is uh
getting information faster and stuff
which doesn't get you close to the truth
but it gets you information faster there
are endless facts but more importantly
um I I always wonder like why we are
given this I really believe that human
potential is pretty much infinite
whatever you can imagine and Beyond we
can do and we are doing we seem to be
doing this like think about how crazy
that is I can wear a headset and I can
do things with my mind and look up the
answer yeah that's insane that's magic
it's crazier than magic but there's a
way to measure that and quantify that
and replicate that so it's not magic I
can do it and I can tell you exactly how
I get there which is even crazier so
uh what what is that what is that
leading us to it is nudging us closer
it's it's like the I think it's very
significant that we're getting a better
understanding of what it's like to be
someone else we are it's it's really
hard to say that an uh Indian or whoever
it might be is thinks about things
differently than I do when I know so
much about how all these human beings
like someone in Iran
um someone in Jordan uh laughs and cries
and bleeds at the same thing I do uh you
know we we it's it's being prejudiced
based on what that person looks like
over there is becoming harder and harder
to justify where it was before we knew
about that we were like well those
people over there are quote unquote
Savages or they're this that and the
other thing and I do think that we are
getting a better understanding of what
it's like to be each other and being
nudged in the same direction I'm not
saying we don't yeah I think that's true
too but why and and uh it's interesting
to think about where that's where that's
leading us to what to what understanding
to what understanding and then when we
have that understanding what are we
going to do about that right and are we
going to pull it together and are the
aliens here to make sure that we don't
[__] it up yeah
yeah that's the the beautiful idea the
terrible idea is that it's all us and
then it's all the big ruse and it's all
just drones that we're doing because we
don't want China and Russia know about
it but we have insane propulsion systems
that operate on gravity and yeah
I think it is
it seems like both
it seems like us and it also seems like
there's some [__] that we we just don't
understand and I don't know if those
people are telling the truth because if
the people that are telling the truth
that there's biological entities and
this is what Jackie Gleason said that
Nixon told him and Nixon took him on
they were drinking you know that famous
story who knows if it's true it's it's a
legend but the legend is that Jackie
Gleason and Nixon were drinking and that
Nixon said you want to see some [__]
aliens and they get on Air Force One and
they fly to some Air Force Base and they
go to a place where they have a crashed
UFO and they have biological beings that
are in freezers and Jackie Gleason sees
this and Jackie Gleason after that has a
house built in Upstate New York that
looks like a UFO he became obsessed with
UFOs afterwards there was a house it was
actually for sale at one point in time
yeah so he has this house that he had
shaped like a UFO and this is like who
knows if this is a true story yeah right
because it's like it was kind of sort of
disputed his ex-wife told the story or
something like that I forgot I I think
truly impossible a secret no I don't
think so really no do you think
generational like generations of of
government bureaucrats can keep
something a secret sure I don't tell the
the people the very highest level know
about it's very few people it's all very
compartmentalized they're always they
monitor everyone's phone calls
everyone's emails everything everyone
does at a top secret clearance level no
way I don't think you're right totally
impossible definitely not right I think
it's impossible listen man they can keep
secrets when people at high levels of
military can keep seeing yeah but people
are just rotating out they're retiring
they're dying yeah they probably wind up
[__] Hillary Clinton and a lot of
those dudes
yeah
yeah but it's not just so fun to believe
in it is possible it's a physically
possible thing to do especially if you
have the right people and they're
indoctrinated in the right way with top
secret clearance and by the way it's not
like these people don't tell their
friends and it's not like there's a
bunch of stories floating around because
there are there's a shitload of stories
that's what I'm saying but why why would
you like I would never keep that a
secret I'd be like yeah here's an aliens
here's the thing when you have senators
and congressmen who find out about this
and they find out that military
contractors are the ones who have access
to this stuff because the back
engineering program has to involve
someone has the capability of recreating
this so who would that be that would be
the people that make jets if you've got
someone who's making you a [__] a
stealth bomber and you have a crashed
UFO those are the people that you want
discussing like what kind of things
you've recovered from a [__] alien
crash and can this be replicated no
here's a problem with you don't you know
me [__] because you don't know
you might be wrong no no no don't say
you're wrong that's the problem with
your theory ready I'm sorry and I love
that you want to believe in this and so
why but here's the problem okay there's
no law there's no written law that says
I'm not allowed to talk about aliens and
I mean at the level the top levels of
clearance like the most secret level
there is no world where if I'm a
government official and I take a bunch
of pictures and I come before Congress
and I go here's my evidence I'm blowing
the whistle there are real aliens you
don't think they would go after you I'd
never go to jail violating your top
secret clearance no because it's not
violating my top secret clearance but it
would be nope because I'd never go to
jail for that because I'd be like you're
going to put me in jail for exposing
what everybody wants to know the whole
world would be like holy [__] you guys
get this is assuming that you have
access to that material to extract there
are enough people whoever the people
maybe maybe not maybe those are the kind
of people that wouldn't do that Brian
listen you [__] communist I don't
like the way you think hi I'm blowing
I'm I'm shredding your UFO no you're not
where you think you are you're just
using these establishments you're
allowed to talk about UFOs never get in
trouble sound like your dad
and you're in here spreading propaganda
to the faithful listeners listen to this
listen to me there are no aliens and if
there are uh we'd know about it because
if there is you're gonna come back on
dressed like a clown agreed agreed
that's my bets I'm making with everybody
now
dressed like a clown I'll do it